are you getting cuz you know your
national and and I've turned on the TV
and I've seen your show do you get
recognized now a little bit more it
happened like in New York it's nice too
because people are very no nonsense like
I'll be on the subway and people would
be like I like your stuff man and then I
get off I'm like that's cool it makes me
feel good I'm doing a little better but
it bites me sometimes like I get
arrogant and that's no good I did had a
situation it's probably about two months
ago where I was walking down the street
in New York and I saw this couple guy
and a girl and they saw me and kind of
like whispered to each other and looked
back and then the guy was like hey will
you take a picture and I was like yeah
of course so I walked up to his
girlfriend and I put my arm around her
and she was like this and then the guy
looks like kind of mad oh yeah and very
quickly I was like oh you wanted me to
take a picture of you like you do just
like Central Park in the background so
that's all right cause I'm good but
those moments await us all
you